麺ちゃーん
はいこんにちははじめポッターです世の中には不思議なことがたくさんある
魔法墓相お化けもそう匂いもまた不思議な匂いがあります一年前ぐらいに動画で紹介し
たこの絶対いけろが出る
魔法の日もまた魔法のアイテムのひとつ1年経った今でもストーン需要が顕在
今も良い会社だと華楼ってちゃんだ
ああああああ
これはねあの本当にすごい二年経った今でも全然
に良い角度だけで0北出ちゃうんですけど今回はこの強力な闇魔法に対抗するためで僕
は光やば今考えましたぜ方がシュークリームの皮が言いたかった仲です
こちら a 阿蘇不良レイアウトフィア西へアスフィアファイバー無臭の消臭スプレー
ですすばらしいな方アイテムだとは思わない
綺麗な手に良いよ瞬間少数天然植物成分なので安心してご使用いただけます香りで
マギーなすことなく
に良いそんなものを分解し6周カッセル本物の消臭剤で都合
病室等の深い集
下駄箱の臭いとかペットエリアタバコの臭い魚の強い
いや関係でいいか二重調整スプレーということは本当に臭いを聞いて文化にする魔法の
スプレーです
本当に愛がいい
ディスプレイをとりあえず準備しますもう一つ消臭ビーズのでかいビーズがたくさん
入ってるんですけども招集
大容量でしっかり消臭これは0ではなくもう物体ですいろいろないやに分解し消臭作用
のある直ぶつけ場主成分などしっかり振動させた消臭剤です
大かっもうどうしようもない良いなんて本当にどうしようもないですよに良い書くだけ
てい
あっ本当にあのまずですごいんですよ匂いがこの闇の力を込めた魔法の上位のソラーレ
とすべての匂いを打つキスこの光のあえて今回はこの闇と光を打ち合わせるとどっちが
勝つのかという検証していきたいと思いますや実に何か国はツっぽい実験ですな完全に
魔法学校
これでもうこの実験が成功すれば臭い書くとゲロが出る
b を a 片に消滅させることが可能かも知れませんちょうなればすごいです本当に
しっかりしてると思います匂いを日本でごまかすというよりも根本的に臭いを消すと
いう消臭スプレーなのでその実力が間違いないと思いますでは
入れていきましょう
[音楽]
me
ぶううううううっ
あまりまたてちゃった本当にものを作りたくないんだよなぁこれなんてほんといつも
一変ちょっと
跳ね返ってねっ
[音楽]
ん
俺を思ってもいけるぞいけるのこれいけるいける持って出せるは買う東洋
ダガーだけ
ええええええ
ぷうううまいっす
[音楽]
じゃがたらありましたカットバサミ付
思いますわー
なんで俺ますこれで相手を読める瞬間にもう狙い作るしかない
あと縁もねえ奴
[音楽]
[拍手]
おっ
あった
やったか
[音楽]
全部入りましたちょっとこれで蓋をしてちょっと時間を置いてみましょう
では封印
[音楽]
ではにより壁とゲロが出てしまう最強の液体 vs へ匂いを打ち消せる
最強の相手この2つのためた結果がこの壷の中に入っていくそれでは尿意を変えていき
ましょう
[音楽]
あれ
me
dea
me あった